yo St no baby and I'm on bootle kev's
podcast it's kind of
cool yo man bootle C show special guest
here he's got the hottest song in the
country right now [__] the West Coast
the country country 310 baby Mr so City
himself welcome sir what's up man for
people who don't know you are a literal
child you turned 18 in what December
January so your birthday's coming up
yeah yeah but as of right now you can't
buy cigarettes you can't uh you can't do
much of anything my son just turned 18
in October so you know you really can't
do much else when you turn 18 except for
like join the Army or yeah join the Army
buy some Mar Bros or something right
what you wouldn't do right yeah uh
you're still in school though right oh
yeah for sure Monday to Friday like uh
like regular high school public school
yeah regular school what's that
like are you like [__] just l at
school I mean like people know the song
like you know but like nobody's like
fanned out freshman say freshman [__]
what is like a freshman thing to say to
you then like oh my God no like a oh
some weird [__] it's just like whatever
you think bro like it'd be weird like
it's like it's like no you're not real
bro like what are you talking about like
get away from me freshman are uh they're
are kind of like a look down upon like
peasants at in a high school setting
right no I think I for me I don't say
peasants I mean it's more like bro I
just I understand you don't belong here
yeah it's like bro I'll give you a
couple month to be like over here I
think the high school starts sophomore
year and then the middle school is all
the way to freshman year in La like
where I'm at over here in Burbank oh
yeah well no so I think like the Middle
School's 7th 8th 9th and then the high
school starts sophomore year yeah I
started ninth High School yeah yeah so
you got ninth grade you got real like
little children running around over
there probably listening to uh you lot
of yeet yeet yeah they love ye at your
school don't they I mean I wouldn't say
at my
school yeah freshman like
Yeet I think all Gres like yeat I don't
like ye you don't why I mean I don't
dislike them but I'm not like why you
don't like ye cuz I'm a [__] grownup
what do you mean what I look like
listening to Yeet as a 36y old man you
know sometimes things just they they
come out and they just go and I'm just
like it's not for me I understand I look
I respect it
I ain't mad at ye seems like a nice kid
just not for me all look but then ain't
that the same as like somebody my age
not listening to like yeah a old artist
and like no you should know he's a
legend but it's like bro I'm 17 but I
wouldn't hold you to that yeah I mean
but you know that's how it go like you
be like top three album all time you say
somebody that's like like if I'm like yo
have you heard nomatic and you're like
nah bro and then someone gets mad at you
but you're a child you know mean albums
have been released and I'm supposed to
just know like that that like like
honestly on this right here what you got
I've maybe listened to that Jay-Z one I
can't name a song though I know I've
listened to it just trying to explore
well you know what's funny is that's the
blueprint too actually that's not even
the first blueprint which was the least
I've listened to it I've listened to
almost all Jay-Z albums but like just
skimming through them like trying to
explore yeah just to kind of do research
yeah like done like homework yeah in a
way and I just trying to see you know
was what was the you keep do you keep
listening to the Jay-Z after though or
do you just say ah I get it I heard it
all right moving on I have a couple JZ
songs that I do like that are older
right I don't know what specific albums
but like it's a couple songs like
college The College Dropout that's
actually album I like that's a great
album uh what about uh like the Carter
the first Little Wayne album oh wait
2008 how would zero three three okay
it's probably songs on there I like know
like lollipop yeah I know lollipop but I
like right yeah like you know that was
Hot Snoop Dog doggy style I probably no
songs on there like what was the biggest
song on that album I mean there's a lot
dude it's doggy style yeah so I yeah my
age you know it's probably top two three
hip-hop album of all time to an old man
like myself yeah fair fair shout yeah
Snoop Dog Snoop Dog has his stuff like
that I like know what are your what's
your upper echelon of alltime great
albums it changes every day well what is
it
today I feel
like I'll would say like Lil Uzi Eternal
take I'll
say uh Lou
y let's start here and you
know I would say Ty the Creator's last
album I forgot the exact name I talk
call me when you get lost call me when
you get lost Delux the deluxe was
amazing too yeah for sure that's my top
three right now when I was I somebody
asked me this when I was in Atlanta and
it was a completely different list but
I'm saying right now like cuz I was just
listening to to the Creator is the
little is that little yada ya m is that
the one that sounds like like he's doing
tame andala kind of yeah like
alternative the trippy Rocky one that
came out yeah not a bad top three just
because of the
courage ever I mean I guess we we could
say that whatever like just to get by
but I'm just saying right now what I'm
like likeing no let's not get by okay
ever let's not just get by come on this
is the boot Lake cat podcast this is
Power
106 respect but it's wow you're crazy
bro anyway um yeah so so ever you got
yti alternative rocket yeah cuz I think
you know I'm going to I'm going to say
it it's ever the reason why I say that
is I feel like that's in the age pretty
well and it was like you said very
experimental mhm his best album for we
appreciate it when like he's no longer
here uh for you this song has gone so
crazy so viral it's
obviously uh I saw you originally had
recorded it on your iPhone which is
crazy like the first first early version
right what is the app on an iPhone you
use is a garage band band lab band lab
band lab so what do the mic is you just
do it into the phone mm-m you I mean you
can if you have like airpods but you can
use your airpod mics and then it records
the vocal so look if you have airpods
you record at the bottom at the phone if
you have the wires like apple wires you
put them in like that's what I did a mic
on you hold it in front of at what point
in time did you go back and re-record it
so it didn't sound like it was recorded
on a phone I never did they just mix my
vocals so the vocals we hear right now
are the OG iPhone vocals yeah besides
the clean version I re-record the clean
version but on my phone again really so
I didn't record so in the studio at all
that's so crazy wow no excuses man no no
I I think I didn't start getting into
the studio until like now like yesterday
yeah so you just have the crib just save
time so crazy I don't have to wait on
the engineer like send my vocals just
send your vocals hey that's impressive
man kudos to you thanks um do you like
uh well first of all there's there's a
few like what has been the one VI cuz a
lot of people have made videos to your
song yeah it seems to be the it like
dance that people are doing what has
been the most surreal moment you've had
with this record where you've seen
somebody post about it or dance to it or
acknowledge it obviously the remix is
[__] huge you got blue face and blue
bucks on it and mustard and all that but
in terms of just like people who have
like posted it like what has been a
surreal moment for you just coming from
being a 17year old kid CJ St CJ stoud
like when I saw him like hitting the
dance or like the squabble that's not my
dance but the squabble and then people
put my song behind it yeah it was like
wow was this last week when he threw for
470 yards broke the this is like the
first couple weeks B oh no Ricky of the
Year Rookie of the Year for it isn't
even I think to bet on it it's like
minus 500 if you bet like he's he's
murdering it you a football fan mhm
rooky of the Year me and TJ St both
rooky of the years you might be right
there uh I mean I got to keep working
but you know what I'm saying
100% uh what's your football team Rams
mhm what so how you've been a Rams fan
for like three years what's your team
I'm Arizona Cardinal fan have you guys I
don't think you guys are well you guys
to the Super Bowl 09 but listen well
Larry Fitz yeah it takes real it takes
real uh intestinal fortitude to be a fan
of the Arizona Cardinals Rams as well
nah y'all just won a Super Bowl two
years ago when did you start becoming a
fan
2017 so what do you know two two three
years of of mediocrity even then with
Jared G y'all were decent who who I mean
who was your team before then there was
no team in La so I didn't have a team I
like players so you're a player guy
who's your favorite football player ever
um I don't know you don't know CJ Stout
there you go Aaron
Donald puka you know about Puka Puka is
nice he's on my fantasy team he is he's
a baller how much money did you put in
uh our League's I think uh the winner
wins $2,400 so it's like $200
per buying we got 12 teams nothing crazy
but it's very competitive it's a bunch
of people who take that is crazy we we
take it too serious $2 is crazy yeah I
mean it's you play Fantasy
Football have you ever played fantasy
football do you know what that is yeah
you've never played is that like a age
thing you're trying to say like cuz I'm
young I don't know dude have you played
fantasy yes for free ESPN fantasy yeah
that's what I do but we put money up so
you set your lineup and you know it's
fun let's play next year when I turn 18
let's do it you could play as a kid no
but like when I turn 18 so then it's
like a thing oh he's 18 now he could
play with us oh that's fair do you guys
do draft nights yeah you guys get drunk
and do draft nights there's some
drinking and some weed for sure do you
feel like the weed like enhan is like
your
pics probably not like you see the
future no I feel like what I do is like
when I'm like trying to like cram and
study before a draft I feel like I
overthink it and then I end up like like
watching a podcast or something that
convinces me to take somebody I
shouldn't have take and then that this
year that didn't happen but this year
I'm actually rolling in fantasy pretty
well but I enjoy fantasy it's very
stressing it is stressful I mean but
realistically I always forget I think
that's why when you put money in you
make sure when it's free you like forget
yeah when you when it's free you forget
especially if it's just for like shits
and giggles but I do fantasy basketball
too you said [__] and what shits and
giggles what's that yeah you know it's
like if you were to say like like you're
doing it for like you're in a free
fantasy league so you're there's nothing
up for grabs you're just doing it for
shits and giggles yeah no but say it and
hit that do the dance shits and giggles
yeah you're funny thanks buddy I
appreciate that what about are you an
NBA guy what do you mean do you like
basketball yeah are you a player guy
there or you a Laker guy Laker not a
Clippers fan me and LeBron have the same
birthday LeBron James he's the goat I
have a LeBron toy right there you're a
LeBron fan yeah he's my favorite
basketball player ever then why do you
have other guys cuz I'm a Suns fan who's
number 32 off the Suns Kevin Johnson uh
that was Jason kid the year that he
domestic Ally violenc his wife and we
traded
him yeah now he's Jesus Christ well when
he was with the sons he slapped he
slapped his wife and then we traded him
that's that literally happened that
number 32 is Jason kid yeah that's a
terrible tone of him if you actually
look at this toy just so people can see
what we're talking
about it's kind of racist like they just
were like this is Jason kid this is not
the way he looks like do you think that
looks like Jason kid like at least could
have got the skin no I'm not the face
kind of like just like the no [__] no
that's not Jason kid dude look at holy
[__] why do you even have that such a
disgrace throw that away because you
know it's cool maybe now it's like oh I
have a fake Jason kid type of thing and
it's not your fault it's not like you
bought a fake Jason kid it's their fault
someone actually gave it to me and look
it won't even stand now it won't even
stand yeah J so Jason K when he was on
the Suns he uh yeah him and his wife
wasn't his hair dyed yeah it was
bleached how' you know that I just seen
it before he had blonde hair he he look
like [__]
Eminem yeah Jason kid in Phoenix had
bleached hair and was [__] smacking
up his wife God bless her and now who'
we trade him to we traded him to the the
nets for Stefon Marberry yeah I know
stepan Marberry didn't he eat like
Vaseline or some [__] he did yes he did
I don't judge him though you know random
tidbits don't you yes I don't I don't
blame him though for eating Vaseline no
let me tell you why CU it looks good no
because the end the day it's like it's
[__] that we might do be like weird as
[__] but like nobody would know cuz it's
like our secret yeah I mean look I
wouldn't eat Vaseline on camera like it
be if if if if in private Stefon
Marberry had this thing where he like
like to hit the
Vaseline but he did it like on cam it
was like early viral moment on was it
like attention I for attention so this I
don't know I think he had just had some
mental issues towards the end of his
career then he ended up going to China
and having a legendary career there they
actually have statues of him in Shanghai
he's like the Jordan of China thanks to
2K I know Stefan Marberry
I didn't know him before like I wouldn't
I mean 2005 baby I mean was he even in
the league in 2005 of course yeah when
did he retire from he was drafted I
think in 99 it was him and uh Kevin
Garnett they were on the timber wolv you
like Kevin Garnett yeah kg was was was
sick for sure Kevin Garnett he seemed
like a good guy like get drunk and go
like to the casino with and he's start
cussing yeah
[__] hell yeah like that like
he'll motivate you like he'll motivate
you to run through a [__] wall right
now yeah that's true I feel like kg
would be the guy who like uh should be a
coach but he's not you know understand
like kg I don't know why he's not
coaching right now but it's probably a
good thing he's not a
coach yeah he probably would get
canceled maybe huh screaming at people
cussing at him yeah yeah he's a wild man
shout out to kg nice guy I've met him a
couple times uh shout out to K we're
going on some tidbits here and I'm I'm
very impressed by your random bleached
hair eating Vaseline tidbits that you
know about random old school players you
are a real Suns fan aren't you yes you
have a son's hat and I have Devon Booker
on my shirt what does have to do with
butterflies though it's just a there's a
brand called um the [__] is this brand
called felt oh is that like free free
promo no no no no no no I bought this
hat so felt they do they did a bunch of
new era collabs and the things of these
butterflies so it's like a son's are you
like a mandatory cap guy like when you
walk out the house you know some guys
like mandatory cap I think I'll get to
that point when I turn like your age
story cap how old are you 36 you're not
that old no I could be your father I
have an 18-year-old son for sure yeah my
kid's a senior in high school just like
you that's kind of dope isn't it yeah so
were you born in what 2010 05 wait I'm
tripping dog [__] no you're off some
[__] dog for real it's my own kid I
don't know his birthday yeah 05 what the
hell yeah cuz
[Music]
I what what's 2010 that's important to
my life yeah 05 yeah you're right
obviously you're right you would know
when you're born so are you working on
um obviously you put singles out and
stuff but are you putting together an
album or you just yeah I'm working on my
my first debut like real studio album
pop it's called pop what's no pop what
do you mean like I'm saying like it's
going to be a pop album oh it's going to
be a pop album nice Popp in what way
though like pop like you're exactly what
you think like you're going to be seeing
fist like EDM yeah all that [__] I think
you're you're lying to me what were you
going to say what was the word you going
to use I think you're full of [__] I
thought was going to say another F word
what the [__] did you think I was going
to say I wasn't going to say Bob Saget
what what did you think I was going to
say What's another word with the F that
rhymes with Saget no I don't know but
like you're me I don't you you're
[__] kidding me you're I don't I'm
confused now I'm droing uh I'm working
on the album it's not a pop album though
is it I know is there EDM on there I
don't know what to categorize it I think
I'm coming out with my own subcategory I
like that I like that I think well I
feel like what's dope about Soak City is
it's kind of like I feel like we haven't
had a fun dope Club record in hip-hop in
like that doesn't involve murder oh my
God I was just talking to when you
listening to you probably waiting for
like the I was like I've been waiting
for this song cuz I DJ I own a club and
it's like all man there's no Club [__]
anymore like like you said it's like all
like op killing music and like you know
and shout out to all those artists
they're cool you know but like just a
fun dope Club song like people can dance
to fun yeah I actually like I don't want
to say the word study it's kind of corny
but I like watched like Little John and
Eide boys growing up like young though
like random like 6 seven eight always
having fun and I used to always watch
those videos and like that motivated Me
Like Chief like old Chief ke videos like
Gucci man like and like I'm looking up
those videos clubs don't even look the
same bro when I like well people used to
dance now they don't dance anymore
everybody's cool as [__] everybody's
cool as [__] everybody's a [__] man
when I go into like clubs and like you
know I perform and stuff it's just like
parties I grew up going to you're still
but hey you're still growing up oh yeah
so parties are like [__] on the club
right now yeah like everybody's in there
fun like people are still trying to be
hard in the corner but like it's
actually lit like now if you go to like
a 21 and up Club right now everyone's
just standing there Fu that shit's
depressing ordering bottles that [__] I
I don't after this [__] I don't have to
go to the club I own a nightclub so
shout out to everybody who buys bottles
and stands there to look cool what's
your Club 11-11 I knew that but I want
you to say it you have to say that [__]
you performed there no I'm saying you
have to I was really worried about
booking you too cuz I was like we have
never booked anybody who's not 18 years
old it's okay you're okay but you you
yeah but you were a performer so it
worked out yeah no I'm saying you had to
say like 11-11 cuz you that's like me
saying oh my new song and I didn't say
this [__] yeah I'm just saying what they
taught me recently but no but it is an
interesting like when you like when you
first came in here you were like what
are you getting into tonight I'm like
uh nothing no I was going to invite
invite you to come play video games with
me tonight what game 2K and Madden maybe
Call of Duty you seem like you like I
think I think I I might I think I'm you
know I'm I'm pretty good at uh at 2K
Madden Madden I'm a little you know this
year I finally picked it back up I I
took a few years off cuz I why cuz
Madden just be trash bro they don't even
try anymore don't say that Electronic
Arts I love you shout out to e is so
City in the game how you say Madden [__]
didn't say is is Soak City in the game
not right now it will be you think so
why not Electronic Arts might not like
it you're with uh you're with the Empire
gets a lot of songs in Madden you know
shout out to the guys over there you'll
be in there yeah but but Madden you know
it'd be nice if they put a little more
effort into the game every year no tell
them fix the game Electronic Arts did
you ever play NFL 2K back in the N you
didn't I've seen videos like YouTube
yeah I say Dreamcast was that [__] dream
what Dreamcast it was a system
Sega Dreamcast the most underrated
gaming system ever Dreamcast yeah they
had like uh the first 2K NBA 2K and NFL
2K were the two uh they started with
Sega fire system didn't last PlayStation
2 merked it but it was uh Dreamcast was
good man I like video games yeah so
what's your like uh what like are you
just doing like the normal [__] fortnite
Call of Duty 2K or yeah like regular
[__] yeah GTA GTA Grand Theft Auto do
you have any uh server you play in on
GTA no I don't play RP I play like just
on my system you just play like the
story mode no like online oh online okay
I'm saying that's different than RP RP
like role play like on the PC where all
like the people like I've seen it it's
it's weird to me I don't do that yeah I
never got into it I talked to T Grizzly
about it he said if someone breaks
character they kill him and kicked them
out like they're done they can't play no
that get serious I watched that but I
never I never jumped into it yeah it's
like you're like it's too real yeah no
it's fun I always thought about like
damn probably doing it cuz it's like lit
but I just haven't done it eventually
probably start your own thing GTA 6 is
about what am I going to call soaked
City man ah see that see what you did
there I mean that's what you would have
to call it right that's very 36 years
old if you like to say that are you uh
that was still 36 years old I know
thanks well listen we do have a you get
like a past though thanks um talk talk
to me about the remix man the remix is a
big deal it was kind of a big statement
for la like to get everybody on one song
have mustard put his his fingers on the
song uh how did that originate and uh
like did mustard reach out to you
originally or mustard just tapped in on
some whole other like just to like
what's up type like showing love right
and then he invited me to the St and I
just like talked to him and we were just
like
talking yeah about talking what were you
guys talking
about anything in did you no we were
watching like Football H the Rams no no
San Francisco the Niner
Brock pie shout out to Brock you like
Brock pie he's from Phoenix well he's
from Gilbert we were watching we were
watching um football and just like I was
drinking uh minimade
watermelon H minimade watermelon and we
were eating
cookies eating or reading eating cookies
I thought you said you were reading
cookies I'm like bro what eating cookies
so cookies minimade watermelon and
football and we ate no boou that's nice
this this a lot of food have you been to
like actual noou yet yes overrated
underrated um right about where it
should be I think it's worth it because
of where the location is in Malibu you
get to see the water yeah it's worth it
I mean it's hype I mean but like if it
was like [__] like if it was like
downtown LA you'd be like me like it
like like you're not going to dodge like
fentanyl smoke and human feces to go to
noou but you would go you go eat it near
the beach you confuse me if you like
downtown LA like the food's got to be so
good that I'm willing to like Risk
walking into a cloud of fentanyl smoke
to eat it you like Habachi I do but I
feel like it's getting out of hand no
you know what I think it is bro huh I
think like it's becoming like the meal
like the like oh yeah like I'm going to
get high and eat Habachi you're right
especially in La people go cuz then it's
like a kid like me that just wants to
just eat habach doesn't care about
consuming anything like that mhm and
it's like I just want Habachi Habachi
line is so crazy yeah unless you just
call in you never just had call it in
the other thing about Habachi is
guarantee you got the shits the next now
you know what it is it's that garlic
butter that [__] garlic butter that
[__] garlic butter pour that [__] on
so good but it's good as [__] huh so
good bro it's so rich I promise you
right now yeah when I go to Benny hanas
I went for my kid's birthday every time
I go I get a pint of garlic butter to
take home now you have a problem in my
refrigerator right now there's a pint of
it's probably Halfway Gone now so I'll
put garlic butter on my sandwich my
burgers that shit's fire do you go in
there and like just dip your thumb oh
yeah oh that's a problem you have
[__] problem yeah I like literally
I'm at Benny Hana and I just tell the
guy I'm like extra garlic butter and
he'll put another blop I'm like nah no
no no not like extra not extra but
extra I love garlic butter but it it
it'll have your stomach [__] up it's
so rich it's so good you have a [__]
problem though for sure no you e you
know anytime I go to benas I'm [__]
for like 2 days on the the toilet cuz I
just eat so much garlic butter and then
I get everything you know what I'm
saying you got to get the [__]
lobster tail with the shrimp everything
you might as well [__] bro what look
look you're just going to get steak and
shrimp get [__] Lobster too buddy got
to get the lobster and then you know
they give you the shrimp and none of my
family eat seafood so I get all my kids
and my wife shrimp so I got all this
[__] shrimp I'm [__] lit at benih
bro you like Ben I mean I don't not like
it it's solid you know it's all right
you know what it is is like you go in
there and like you're just sitting next
to like a bunch of
strangers that [__] be awkward as [__]
yeah and it's like you have you can hear
everybody's conversation so it's like
yeah you almost want to go with like
four or five people otherwise like if
you go there on a [__] date you're a
weirdo like if it's your first date or
like you're still okay you're saying
first dat if you're still not
[__] obviously I hope you're not cuz
you're a child no see inappropriate for
me to bring that up with a child in my
presence I apologize but if you're
you're not if you're not
smashing you should not be you shouldn't
be going to Benny hanas yet cuz CU
because you can't really get to know
somebody because you're getting to know
somebody in front of a bunch of
strangers right bana is like they it's
like I'm married they're they're having
a they're celebrating a birthday you're
you know getting off of work you just
want to get some food they're [__]
they're on a date on a date [__] two
kids on the side oh yeah is a wild place
in the middle of you guys will be like a
guy that's got out of jail and and his
parents or something his kid like it's
like so [__] I get really
disappointed to when I go to Benny Han
and we don't get the Asian like cook and
like we get the white dude i' be like
bro I'm like I'm like dog I don't trust
this guy to have cool tricks like like
like like would you like would you like
a white dude cooking your Benny hanas
like that's terrible it be like if you
went to like uh you know a
[__] like a marisco place and you and
some dude named Chad was cooking the
food You' be like n bro Chad might [__]
up [__] Jose Chad might be in kitchen
[__] it up though like in a good way
nah bro n no I'm saying but like what
are you trying to say I'm trying to say
if I go to a place I want the [__] if
I go to a Asian restaurant I feel a lot
better if Asian people were making the
food I
don't bro if I go to a [__] for
example if I went to a Mexican
restaurant I'm talking about like tacos
like a real legit Mexican spot and it's
some white people cooking the food
that's a problem time out I be real bro
the Asian Asian
restaur that's
fair but I'm also saying the guy who
comes out and Cooks it in front of you
with the hat and [__] I just I just you
know I feel like them dudes got all the
tricks bro like they got the choo choo
they got the [__] they you know they
make the eggs disappear and [__] and
then like the white dude will cook it
and all he could do is the onion Tower
bro the that's all he's got in his
Arsenal you know what I'm saying that's
all he's like I don't want to get
cancelled like you're going down a wild
path right now Kev um have you have you
well first of all how far along are you
in recording your pop album or your
album no my rap album my rap my rap your
first album uh probably working for like
72 hours that's it so you've only been
recording for three
days why are you looking like that I
don't know why you looking at me like
that BR that's how is that how you like
look at chicks in the club no I'm
married no like what's your name how do
you get how do you cut into a girl you
know what cut into a girl means like
that sounds wild cutting to a girl like
how do you how do you like talk to a
girl I got that from a Detroit artist go
ahead I'm married Bro what what does
that have to do anything uh I'm saying
like how did you used to talk to like I
always go the giggle the panties off
Route I'm so like yeah that's like a 36
year old answer I'm 17 yeah I was can
you translate it uh make a girl
laugh if you could be funny make the
girl laugh then you know she becomes
less you know like her guard her guard
might get let down a little bit more and
then she might want to get to know you
now if you're like just the cool guy you
know everybody can be the cool guy but
can you make a young lady
laugh I understand how are you cutting
into young ladies pause or I don't know
dog that's a wild thing to say um I got
it from artist his name is
um yeah a Detroit artist what's his name
no Michigan artist let's just be
Michigan n but which Michigan artist
Flint Flint who is it RMC m Mike oh
great guy you know Mike yeah he's been
on my show he's hilar got from Mike see
the thing the thing is it could it could
mean some crazy [__] I don't know but I
just know like that's what he says in
the song like like that and I just like
they got the funny them Flint dudes got
the funniest bars like No Cap yeah like
Rio and him and even like free Rio shout
out to cash kid from Detroit he's so
fire cash kid is Hard Cash kid says
crazy [__] he got some bars bro like he
he's got he freestyle on your show I saw
that [__] yeah he's got some sports
references and cash kids crazy did he
say something about the Suns I don't
remember I don't think so oh yeah no so
what like do you just you don't probably
have to hit on girls at your school they
probably are just like you know sliding
you little notes cuz you're you know
you're 310 baby you're like is that a
thing anymore why are you sliding me
notes I'm not is a h that was [__]
weird question is that a thing anymore
in school like how do y'all communicate
in school these days is there notes or
is it just text like what is it no what
do y'all do what do you mean like how
like how you like like if a girl likes
you she just GNA come up to you like yo
what's your
Snapchat what who the [__] uses Snapchat
I don't know bro Snapchat's popping
right now have you seen all the
celebrities saying like my Snapchat is
lit Snapchat is breaking off Brad right
now have you peeped I'm just like into
like the real business world and I've
been seeing I know why I have a Snapchat
show it does well yeah I see we have to
talk about that you should have I [__]
with Snapchat Snapchat is is lowkey like
I said Who uses Snapchat only because I
don't as of right now but Snapchat still
in that bag I don't use Snapchat at all
it's not even on my phone but you have
like the [__] like oh they're breaking
bread yeah no no no yeah like I have a
guy who just handles my show and like
they their the way they pay their
content creators is way better than
everybody else are you a a pull pork
type of guy barbecue love me some ped
por you love barbecue don't you I don't
love like I'm not like you what the [__]
like I love barbecue you don't like
barbecue I do like it but it's not
what's your favorite food thing what do
you love Mexican okay yeah I mean we
live in you know yeah yeah I love me
meican food and then it would probably
be I like sushi Mexican food Sushi Smash
Burgers Lobster oysters barbecue good
seafood but you know the thing with
seafood is you can't attach it to like a
Mexican uh so food like it's like it
goes to different things there's Mexican
style everything no what I'm saying is
that like it like goes like you know
like orange chicken is obviously going
to one thing right yeah yeah but then
like fried chicken goes to one thing
well like on the on the Asian or on the
uh Mexican tip you could have Ceviche
I'm a food connoisseur are you so what's
your favorite food pulled pork um no
that's like top 15 that's a hey I put it
up there if I go to a barbecue spot I
always get the pull pork sandwich it's
my go-to you know what's funny though at
barbecues they never have pool pork only
at the like restaurants like at
barbecues it's just ribs links hot dogs
baked beans potato salad depends on
where you go man and Pepsi have you been
to
Texas yes well you got to get like
Austin barbecue I've been to Austin did
you get barbecue there Stone Cold Steve
Austin he's there that's where he he's
from yeah the Texas rattlesnake you
already know man it's Thanksgiving week
right here we got a shout out to my
bookie man this is an exclusive offer
only happening this week y'all my bookie
if y'all don't know I be hitting these
super teasers on my bookie every Sunday
I put together four picks put them on a
super teaser plus 13 I've been banging
them out every week all right if you've
been follow me on Instagram you know but
listen right now we have a special offer
that's only this week and it's very
exclusive to the bootle C podcast you're
going to get a 110% deposit match up to
$1,000 I want y'all to know what that
means if you put in 1,000 bucks they're
going to match that $1,000 with 110%
deposit match that means they're going
to give you ,00 bucks in free money to
gamble with mybookie.ag you're only
going to get that if you use the the
promo code bootleg that's right use that
promo code bootleg there's
110% deposit match uh up to th000 bucks
that means you're going to get $1,100
back if you deposit $1,000 now this is
only happening until this Sunday coming
up the 26th all right then it's a wrap
110 this is unheard of by the way this
is [__] insane 110% deposit bonus if
you want to gamble on Sports if you want
to hit the real Casino they got they got
Blackjack roulette all that NFL on
Turkey Day uh NFL on on Sunday NBA Black
Friday look all of it you got to sign up
with that promo code
bootle right now at
mybookie.ag put in that first deposit
now look the minimum deposit to get this
bonus is 50 bucks anything over50
dollars they're going to um match 110%
of mybookie.ag use that promo code take
advantage it's just this week what the
[__] are we doing go do it all right
also want to give a shout out to our
good Folks at Imperial extraction baby
you already know what it is woo they got
these pre-rolls man check out these
pre-rolls la king Kush I've been smoking
these all week the cereal milk what dope
about um Imperial right now is you can
get hooked up with a free that's right a
free free 2 G thca Diamond Infuse
pre-roll one of these with any order all
right each pre-roll comes with 1.5 grams
of topshelf flour so far I think this is
my favorite the cereal milk
also a half a gram of pure thca diamonds
and these reusable glass tips you see
that it's a
reusable that's a glass tip all right if
you want to get hooked up with this all
you got to do is head to Imperial
extraction. use the code bootleg at
checkout use the code bootleg at
checkout at Imperial extraction. comom
they're sending you a free one of these
baby what are we talking about plus can
we give a shout out to their Vape pod
system man I'm loving the Vapes that
they got these THC enhanced live resin
Vapes um the pods are so fire the way
they click in they like click in so it's
like a magnet or something whatever
they're doing with these is fire all
right this is the battery let's do it on
camera just so everybody can see real
quick this is an imperial battery pod
system we pop this bad boy
open you see it okay then you come in
here you get some of this tropical punch
sativa because we don't want to uh we
don't need that indicia right now it's
still early [__] it there we go there we
go right and we get it
out there's the Pod now check this out
this is the game changer watch
this just like that just like that we're
in there we're in there we can smoke all
right goes in it goes out shout out to
Imperial man don't forget go to the
website Imperial extraction. mus code
bootleg at checkout and you're going to
get a free 2 Grand pre-roll right now
let's get back to the interview thank
you yeah they got in my opinion the best
Barbecues in Texas that's argument I
heard Nashville or some [__] Memphis
Memphis people say Memphis then there's
Kansas City uh I'm going to say Texas
got it though did you eat today yeah I
did eat today how many times once what'
you eat this morning I had uh some pizza
for lunch I didn't eat this morning oh
yeah you don't eat breakfast you're not
breakfast I usually try to have like a
black coffee in the morning oh cold brew
coffee Costco brand yeah the Kirkland
Signature you know yeah yo Kirkland's
got some [__] have you been to Costco
lately
lately Costco no Costco's A vibe but no
like I don't like going to the store why
not just like boring sometimes yeah like
let's just get the food and leave
[__] s Costco be in line for 30
minutes yeah Costco is a serious line no
Let It Be holiday you know I I never
understood the science behind Costco's
store but now I do what is it what what
didn't you understand like you know like
you go to V it's like V if you go to
[__] R is rals but like Costco is
like the [__] whole like you know
what I'm saying no Costco is wild but
it's like I never understood and it's
like I guess it's like wholesale [__]
it's like a science behind it and then
like actually I do like big like
research on I got do homework on hella
[__] like random [__] like like how they
like design I mean structure the stores
to have certain [__] in the front and
not the back they make the hot dogs
cheap on purpose so people come and eat
and then try to go shop like it's like a
whole like yeah just like how Ikea they
have a play place for kids like it's
like random [__] but [__] like that is
what like makes it hit though Target
needs to step their [__] game up yeah
Costco [__] on target for sure no I
wouldn't say that I like Target I like
Target's cool but Costco's like man they
got that Kirkland C Target was a [__]
when I was younger popcorn in in in a
little icy
drink Pizza the thing you know the thing
is I love Target yeah tar it's good huh
tar how do you spell that the way you
spell smells I mean that sounds like a
[__] perfume tar by Target oh if they
did some Target perfume and it was tar
by Target but it read just Target by
Target that'd be kind of I don't know if
that's smart or not I don't think target
has that much seasoning they probably
don't I think target has just been doing
so like well and they're at like a
they're coasting they're just like you
know they're not like they're just no
they're coasting yeah to where like what
do they need to change at the end of the
day I mean as long as their [__]
quarterly earnings aren't dipping too
much like they're [__] Target at the
end of day Target is always going to eat
I never understood when you drive by
Costco and there's all the people in
line for uh for gas MH I'm like how much
cheaper is the gas for people to like
wait in the line of cars like are you
going to wait in that line for 10 cents
off a gallon like how much cheaper is it
and do they even have Costco commercials
I don't think so think about it they
don't even need to [__] make
commercials for their gas bro that's how
Tesla is Tesla has they spend no money
on marketing or advert or no money on
advertising or marketing Zer have you
ever seen a Tesla commercial never they
don't exist it's enough on the internet
but I'm saying that Tesla does never
made a commercial yeah I mean they don't
need to really no they just got Elon
he'll just go Joe Rogan and everybody
eat it up you know what I mean what do
you mean by that like Elon Musk is their
commercial you know they do the the roll
outs and then like a bunch of YouTube
creators will make reviews that's his
ading same thing with apple you know
what I'm saying it's like why are you
covering up your shirt I'm not cuz you
knew I was going to say something about
Deon Booker Deon Armani Booker man you
know what I'm saying you know his middle
name yeah that's [__] wild why he's
yo he's like our [__] He's our our
Kobe in
Phoenix we drafted him you know what I'm
saying he's been our guy Booker's our
guy yeah he's our Kobe what you mean you
just said his middle name though I did I
feel like it's cool that you're aware
that means you're just like a very like
yeah you know good like I mean you're
you're a great fan like you know like
you know his middle name but like the
fact that you said that right here it's
like dude I don't even know
[__] LeBron's middle name bro I don't
think he has a middle name I think
so I don't think he does I feel like I
would know it like Michael Jordan's
middle name is Jeffrey I feel like I've
heard that Michael Jeffrey
Jordan I don't think LeBron has a middle
name I feel like I would know that
but I could be
wrong Michael Jackson Michael Jordan
LeBron James all have the last name that
starts with a J so what are you trying
to say I don't know but my last name
don't say it doesn't start with a j I
wasn't to say it oh go ahead starts with
an X starts with an X yeah
Xavier
no was not a lot of X names just x h
just kidding hey no but you know how
like like uh what's elon's like kids
name it has like the like his kid that's
what I was getting at you saw I was
rerouting it back to you know his kid's
name is uh I don't know it's like when
you used to like try to use the phone
while somebody was using your dialup
internet and you heard that noise that's
his kid name the [__] are you talking
about yes I'm talking about AOL days bro
you definitely wasn't born yet I could
tell cuz you said bruh what the [__] is
bruh the hell is that and you smacked
your legs you're excited aren't
you [__] you're [__] hilarious I am
this kid is funny right here 310 baby is
a hilarious guy um you know they're
trying to get me to rap 10 more years do
you want to rap 10 more years I think
about it sometimes sometimes I want to
do like other things I feel like you uh
you should like be in movies or shows or
something I feel like you're you're very
funny you have a great you have a very
dry sense of humor what the hell you
some y was funny what do you mean dry
that means you're you're you're like
your your humor is dry it's like it
depends on the day in the
moment kind of I don't know about that
no I'm saying
like you like how the producer who
doesn't have a mic just interjects
himself in but he just said funny Marco
though you think I'm like funny Marco I
think there a lot of people you could
have said said hey shout out funny Marco
though but like you know like did you
see Kevin Hart he just yeah he's like
he's like I just came here he's like
he's like I just came here and you're
wasting the time for this like sh Kevin
har when Kevin Hart said yeah we all got
a doppelganger like you're yours a seal
and he was like why you know people that
are like in like the music I mean not
music but like like movies and [__] do I
know people like that like do like [__]
like that I know some folks that are in
the in the industry that's to like get
me and movies tell them look out doing
no baby I know a couple of people tell
them man tell me tell me [__] it you
know bro you should do so is that
something you want to do movies yeah I
want to do like movie show like
different [__] I don't just want to be
Rapp I feel like you could ride a TV
show like you could do a pilot you know
only if you knew only if you knew like
you could have a pilot and try to Get It
produced or you could self- produce it
you know I think what I'm trying to do
is I'm trying to just relax a little bit
because I feel like once it it starts go
we're not going to stop you understand
did you ever watch Tyler's uh show that
he had on uh was it on Comedy was it on
Comedy Central Cartoon Network was it
was it loyer Squad oh yeah I have
something like that cooking up that's
what I'm saying I feel like you could do
something like that when I mean cooking
up is like in my head like I've thought
of things like that it's in here yeah do
you know like one side of your brain
does something that the other side does
do vice versa like it's like you know M
I saw you just got brought out by beia
yeah sing a beia song uh there a whole
lot of money no sing it not just say the
title I'm not going to sing it it's a
whole lot of money that's so offbeat
though I understand though I like the
London I appreciate the London [__] the
[__] has sh has a coal no B is fire I'm
that [__] she's fire was that
fun coming out with
beia yeah yeah you going to come out
during Camp flog with anybody ready yeah
I'm coming out with Kendrick really so
you're going to be a part of Hill set
are you a hillbilly no yeah no why are
you nodding yes I didn't
say no I'm just I'm not coming out with
Kendrick I like someone should bring you
out why who am I got the hottest [__]
song in the country in La for sure
you're like the number one record that
has like it's like peak time you that's
cool and [__] but I just want to get
some food I'm
hungry some pool pork no that's too
aggressive for today it's a Friday
that's like some Sunday [__] you know
what that's real Friday you feel like
you you know you want to be a little
active for the rest of the weekend you
eat a pool pork sandwich you might want
to take a nap no it's just like would
you like oh would you just eat we're
going to go to the club oh [__] pool
pork what the [__] is wrong with you
you're sick [__] you're going to eat
[__] pool pork before you go to the
club is that not some different [__]
it's kind of different yeah pport before
the club is wild that's wild like maybe
sush Sushi before the club maybe some
Ramen H you like Ramen yeah I I Ramen
yeah who your favorite uh right
obviously you're kind of like a part of
this young class of La guys who are
killing R now is there any of your peers
do you think I really fit in that no I
don't actually at all but I was going to
say do you like is there anybody in La
that you you feel like you're influenced
by or that you uh that you're fans of
that you know know that obviously you
got blue bucks on the remix blue face
all those guys yeah to a certain extent
you know I don't like though it's like
oh yeah like he got this for me or this
style for me right like you're just
doing your own thing no no no it's not
talking about me I'm saying in general
like how this go like in general it has
nothing do me I mean I don't really have
it's really any talk about me like I'm
just it's like oh like he copyed this
this guy copy this guy this got this guy
but it's like bro like still like Artist
Artist still mhm even if you don't know
it subconsciously you can steal some
[__] yeah no that's true and I like on
my new song Walk bro they saying oh
Kodak kodak's hard as [__] like walk
walk like from kodak's s right but
subconsciously I could already boom I'm
not thinking Kodak did it let me do it
but it was already like already knew
start in your head yeah and I'm sure if
Kodak heard it he probably like it's
cool like you know what I'm saying like
[__] gets said over and over just like
this growing up I would hear songs that
they was people will sample like a a bar
or two from another song JayZ used to do
that all the time yeah I I mean even
like the hook people used to make hooks
out of that like bring them out bring
them out the ti [__] that's like a Jay-Z
bar that just got chopped up I see and
you see I thought that was like this his
original [__] but I'm saying like you
see how people do that then it's cool
right but then it's like bro like people
do that I mean still like an artist at
the end of the day like don't just
[__] and everybody right now is just
taking old beats and old songs and just
make like that shit's whack to me it's
so whack it's cool but like N I don't do
that [__] it was it was cool for like 3
months and then it was like oh
everybody's just lazy when I hear music
today like it it makes me just like I'm
not motivated like I'm not you not
saying you know like like hip hop is
supposed to be like real competitive
it's not it's like every right now the
competitiveness has everything to do no
it involves everything but the music for
sure it's like who just bought the
newest Shane 100% who just bought the
newest car but everybody's putting out
[__] music but the consumer has no
choice but to digest it cuz that's the
only thing that's out that's that's a
very fair assessment you know I'd say
with music right now um you know how
like all the Blockbuster movies right
now are kind
of like spin-offs or like sequels
everything's in a shitty place and I
think and I feel like music's the same
thing like they're just recycling old
ideas the same thing with movies it's
like cuz they need people like me that's
that's like behind or like the creative
with these companies they need people
like me the people that are [__] in
charge of these companies are like doing
the creative [__] are old as hell have
no type of seasoning all their Creative
Juice is burned they do hard drugs so
their creative process is [__] and
it's like somebody like me that's clean
that hasn't digested any type of drug
and the creativi da da da da da da da
but we're going to overlook him because
he hasn't done enough right they want
you to have 20 years of experience
you'll get there man no I could be there
now I was going to say for you uh how do
you make sure that um you kind of keep
you have a great head on your shoulders
but obviously you're you're in a spaces
where you're going and traveling and
doing nightclub gigs and you're you know
in an environment that most kids that
are 17 aren't around
so how do you make sure you kind of keep
your head straight and and kind of keep
all sales moving forward cuz I remember
when we tried to book you I remember uh
Gentry was like I got to check with his
mom I was like that's tight I love that
like you know what I'm saying like for
you how do you make sure that like this
Mission you're on stays you know stays
what just stays on on on track and you
know a lot of times fame money can kind
of like deviate you from yeah I think
regardless of fame or money I'll be okay
as long as I have HBO
Max I watch Like
documentaries yeah in class sometimes
when I get bored I watch Like cupcake
documentaries like how cupcakes are made
and ice cream I'm allerg to ice cream
though I'm L to Dairy so I eat vegan
occasionally I'm not a vegan I I'm not a
vegan but I eat like vegan ice cream and
[__] do you know any good vegan places
continue I
don't oh I don't know if I like that or
not because then it's like you're not
like it's 2023 you're not like socially
like sensitive no to that I'm not to
like my My Vegan
thing uh Germaine de PRI has vegan ice
cream but who's going to Atlanta to get
some ice cream I think it's at Walmart
who goes to Walmart you go to Walmart
yeah you seem like a Walmart guy for
sure go to Walmart get some eggs but
remember I told you I don't even go to
the store but I might try one D
Walmart's solid especially so when the
next time you in the South which I saw
your tour got announced your I mean it's
not a tour but it's something like that
right a little run you're going to be
going and and picking up some bags and
doing your music some bags yeah some
money right no so you're doing all that
for free no okay I'm confused anyway if
you're in the South and you guys are
just bored if you're in Florida just go
to any Walmart just hang out why people
watch man Florida Walmart hits different
it's like a club nah it's like it's just
different it's just like what does it
smell
like
smells like [__] Aroma has a lot to
do with Mar
Reds Republicans
and do they do they do they eat vegan I
don't think so it doesn't seem like a
republican would eat vegan are you
you're not vegan vegan you just you just
have to have vegan ice
cream when you say Vegan vegan are the
vegan's capital V I don't know I just
you know you're you're going to eat me
right you said you like Po Pork yeah no
I just like dairy dairy like things I
would have dairy lactose intolerant no
I'm allergic but things that have dairy
I would eat like the alternative which
would be the vegan you know what saying
you can't have
cheese you can't have regular
cheese that's a problem you have to eat
vegan this brand is from Arizona
actually Valley boys I don't doubt that
that was a but you can't have
cheese that's crazy vegan cheese is
disgusting do you play golf no never why
h just uh play golf do you play golf yes
hey what up y'all we got to stop the
interview tell you about our good Folks
at King pom that's right let me tell you
about King pom man it's all smoking over
here what I love about King pom turpine
infused flavor in each one of these
These are the margarita now this is kind
of the wave I've been on recently these
Margarita ones are [__] fire no
tobacco no nicotine straight raw organic
fresh leaves um and what's dope is they
got the tip you squeeze the tip you hit
one of these boys and you just get hit
with that flavor man you get hit with
that flavor no matter how big or small
the Palm is you know what I'm saying
this is what's dope too uh King Palm if
y'all don't know man they're one of the
leading Brands when it comes to this
real like organic smoke light that's why
I like them I like to smoke clean
nothing smokes cleaner than a King Palm
so if you're in your hood you're in your
neighborhood you're in your
[__] City your area wherever
you're at go your local liquor store
they're going to have King poms all
right so pick them up there you could
also go to 7-Eleven or this is what I
suggest you do right
now come on shout out to the king poms
man go to the website King pom.com if
you go to King pom.com you use the promo
code bootleg this is what we're doing
50% off whatever you order they got so
much at King pom.com not only do they
got the
leaves not only do they got the
Grinders not only do they got the gas
trays they got them all the cones
50% off all the smoking accessories all
the leaves you need all the flavors 50%
off King pom.com promo code boot leg
also speaking of [__] you're going to
get some money off of our family our
dogs our our listen I'm going to uh
Tampa to go DJ for these guys holiday
party Odd Socks baby the holidays are
here now is the time time to go to
oddsock official.com and use that promo
code bootleg all right use it right now
and guess what you're going to get 20%
off at checkout now the dope think about
odd Sox they got all the crazy licenses
they just locked down Coca-Cola recently
yeah look at those they just locked down
Hasbro so they got Power Rangers
Transformers all that I mean look they
got cheit bro you know what I'm saying
they got Hershey's chocolate bro they
got WWE they got Breaking Bad they got
Top Ramen they got the draws they got
the socks they got the slippers they got
the Hat they got the belt whatever you
need oddsock official.com load up for
the holidays gift odd Sox to your loved
ones whatever they're into there's an
odd Sox for it odd Sox official.com use
the promo code bootleg when you check
out save 20% off let's get back to the
interview shout out to the homies over
at Blue Chu man that's right blue Chu
everybody always ask me does blue Chu
work well you don't take my word for it
try it for free for a month by using
that promo code bootleg right now blue
has the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Calis uh it's all wrapped up
into a blue chewable form delivered
right to your doorstep in discret
packaging no doctor's
appointments uh are needed all right you
don't have to go into the doctor
everything's online go to blue.com all
right sign up with that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free if
your dick ain't [__] it's time to get
a [__] again again you know what I
mean you're dealing with a little
erectile dysfunction maybe a little
anxiety at work maybe you're stressed
out maybe you're just married to someone
you're tired of [__] let's be honest
sometimes you need a little extra you
know a little extra some some to get you
over the Finish Line get that blue chw
baby blue chw try the first month for
free they're going to give it to you for
free a month supply for free go to
blu.com use the promo code bootleg right
now thank me later let's get back to the
interview you never played why I've been
to like a driving range the [__] I've
been to shoot around in the gym like Top
Golf you've been to Top Golf that's like
dve Buster's basketball yep no so you
going to like I've been a top golf it's
fun it's very fun you get some
mozzarella sticks and they have donuts
and you can like inject like chocolate
and jelly and [__] you can inject I
don't know like in the donut like don't
think weird bro no I'm just saying that
just sounds like a I like just bring me
the dut how I'm supposed to eat it I
don't want you to bring bring me the
donut so I have to do extra work to get
it to where I want it to be I wonder if
a grown man came up with that like let's
inject chocolate somebody did yeah
probably a grownup think so yeah like
grownup what are college students
grown-ups to me it doesn't seem like it
no it's like technically they are
according to the law they are I mean duh
I feel like you don't really become like
a real adult until like 24
25 or unless you have a kid do I see my
age huh do I like come off like you seem
older like so when I was your age I had
a pregnant girl my girl was pregnant
when I was 17 High School yeah so I was
like all I kind of was like forced into
like you know what I'm saying like damn
I got to support a child so don't don't
mess that up you know no that's why I
always just play my game you play video
games just get on that 2K have you
played the OG map on fortnite since they
brought it back no they brought it back
I've been busy I'm been super busy bro
I've noticed can you buy me NHL for my
birthday I've always wanted to play NHL
but I I don't want to spend my money on
that i' rather YouTu the hockey game NHL
yeah I don't know like do they still
make those I I've never played uh I like
the last time I played a hockey game was
Sega maybe and Sega was like 99 no like
sure can I buy you the one from the year
prior so it's discounted don't buy it I
don't want it so like I can get you NHL
completely lost interest NHL 2021 that
way you can see if you like it maybe if
you like it then I get you the new one
after this interview I think Electronic
Arts is going to lose interest in
me shout out to EA
sports EA Sports It's in the game I've
always wanted to do voiceovers too cuz I
could like make my voice
deeper I think we all could make our
voice deeper do it I just did it do it
again yo that's [__] show me then
you show me EA Sports like that that's
actually very high quality not bad look
man uh the song's going crazy
congratulations the you're trying to end
it I mean we keep going no I can tell
you're trying to end it I've been
through this a couple times I know where
this
goes whoa yeah D you're doing big things
I would love to have you back bro do
beat artists really come back bro like
real [__] they be like oh yeah you going
to come back yeah bro I'm got to come
back bro realistically bro you're not
coming back bro or if you come back
it'll be like in 10 [__] Years bro no
that's not true I have I have um next
time I'll come back but only if you have
chicken tenders and Friesen fries I that
I we just had uh we have people come
back all the time do they
eat I just had the 41 kids uh Jen Carter
and Kyle rich and then from New York
yeah I'm familiar they got the bent
record that's going crazy they came back
twice in like three months and the first
time they came we all drank black coffee
together cuz they never had coffee oh
they they spit it out they weren't fans
oh it's okay you like black coffee um or
do you like Flavor do you like coffee at
all I've had coffee before I don't just
drink it though like you seem like you
like a a coffee guy I'm not a coffee guy
right why do I see him that way huh I
mean I have coffee here Kirkland brand
that's the only reason Kirkland
Signature baby you want to
deal oh I would love a deal with
Kirkland say it and the tell him yo
Costco drop the bag baby I'm Kirkland
out at the crib all right now
describe water bottles describe the
taste and how it feels but look in that
camera and tell them like how how does
it make you feel you have to press that
that's what I noticed IAL well I can't
give up the sauce but just know like I'm
getting laced up back at home at Empire
you know yeah the The Hub you know the
you know they lace me up on certain
things I can't give you the sauce I'll
completely have to charge you I have I'm
going to set up a patreon so I can give
up my sauce I have all the business
sauce right now just you get some good
sauce uh you get any sauce from gazi yet
any good advice from him um if I tell
you yeah you have to just disappear okay
I mean
what about no nothing uh aspiring
artists can what about you you've you've
been obviously you've been on a quite a
ride the last few months is there
anything you've learned as an aspiring
artist that some game you could give to
some artists that are maybe watching
this that haven't necessarily broke out
yet anything you've learned about the
music industry I'm not going to lie cuz
that's very bad and you get in trouble
for that in school for lying okay that's
why I don't lie at school but I will
tell you this when you were talking I
completely lost interest Midway oh word
up but you know it's Tik tok's fault
because of like attention span please
reiterate or like say one more time I
was just saying what have you learned
about the music industry in the small
amount of time that you've oh yeah yeah
I got feel like you could kind of like
share with artists maybe who are
watching this who are new um just be
yourself
and stay away from like Chinese food in
San Francisco cuz I was in the Empire
studio and that [__] made my stomach
hurt maybe it was just hella grease I
have to stick to my traditional like
panda food chain you know what I'm
saying cuz I don't know what the hell I
have they got all that MSG
man that MSG Madison Square Garden n
some I don't know what it stands for but
they say the MSG is in most Chinese food
but it's not in
Panda it I mean rock with panda panda
solid you get the little uh the crab
Rons the cream cheese puff thingies um I
I don't think the those are there for
people like me orange
chicken what's the go to Honey sesame
chicken yeah and if they don't have that
cuz sometime they don't have it orang
orange chicken it's like the coconut
shrimp too or the the Almond shrimp with
the with the pecans in it what is it the
shrimp that they got there they have two
shrimps they got one shrimp I'm a I'm a
food kind of SE and I think they only
have one shrimp yeah that's what I'm
talking about it's good shrimp you said
coconut but then you said almond no I
think it's like some sort of nuts or
some [__] pecans in the shrimp at Panda
next time I come can we eat food I think
it'll just make it a lot more like you
know because it feels like I'm in the
principal's office and I'm very very
familiar do you understand you've been
there a
lot principal's office no I don't get in
trouble but I don't even do anything
have ever been in the principal's office
once yeah what happened I was helping
them with
something do I seem like a bad kid to
you no you seem like a great kid what do
you mean by that seem like a nice kid no
elaborate I overthink so you have to
explain completely you just seem like a
kid that would not be in the principal's
office when I talk to the team like they
have to get me wise they can't just tell
me da da cuz I overthink h I don't
overthink a lot but I'm saying like
certain things like bro don't just be
like come on cam let's go outside why
cuz it's pizza or something let's go
grab right okay do you double dip in
like say you're like with your family
you guys are eating and [__] you guys
have chips and guac do you like grab the
chip and double dip in your guac just
because you feel like you're the man in
the
house wait so if I take the chip right
are you asking if I put it in the guac
bro do I go guac to mouth and then do
you double dip do you double dip bro
when you're eating chips and guac at
your home when it's like a family get
together do you d i do I take one chip
out of the bag I put guac and then I eat
the whole chip and then I'll do it again
another different chip Oh I thought you
double dip I was just asking like
because you're like the man of the house
you I feel I feel like it's super weird
if you were to bite half of a chip and
then go back in people do that who it
just hits different when you double dip
it tastes way better you do that uh no
so then how do you know
dog that was the funniest funniest
[__] giggle ever you said dog oh hey
D A WG or dog G like Snoop
Dog hey guys wait all right guys I'm
here with ble Kev he's like hot us out
right now man at what he does and he he
best what he does soble dip some chips
you interruped my outro so now I think I
feel like I have to do it again don't
look all right I'm going kick back do
what you must I wait till you finish
taking your
sip I think it's done shake it in the
mic so he can get ASMR
ASMR yeah oh ASMR you seem like a ASMR I
would pay money to see you do a ASMR
video where like you know they have the
black the black background have you had
black gloves on eating hot wings but
like hella hot how much money would you
pay me uh [__] like probably like $150
that's my allowance 150 bucks wait you
got an well I mean yeah I'm lying yeah
do people actually get allowance bro or
is that just like in the movies and [__]
I mean I feel like that's a old thing u
i don't I never had like an I never
really like I'm not like a spender are
is your is your mom she your mom helps
you with all your finances and stuff
because you got a lot of money coming in
now that you have a hit record what do
you mean by that I mean you're also
doing live shows I'm saying like I wear
$15
shoes those are 110
these aren't even mine you got Air
Forces on these aren't mine though but
I'm saying like you you're wearing other
people's forces yeah you can catch
athletes
foot I like Air Forces these are mine
but no listen how many Wares before you
you're making money you're talking about
me making money bro the F bro who do you
think I bro you're making money but I'm
trying to get like you so are you you're
doing better than a lot of 17-year-old
human beings
do I have any Balenciaga on well if I
mean do I have any Gucci on but you're
not a [__] boy you know what I'm saying
what the hell does that mean I just mean
like I just I just judge guys that
you're [__] Rich well listen you know
what it is you're filthy you got to
always be the guy who lets you have to
wear the designer and not to let the
designer wear you I've never wore
designer at all I don't think I ever
will cuz you'll see a lot of guys
wearing designer and you'll be like bro
that's a lot I wear designer but it
would be like lowkey [__] yeah like a
belt you know what I'm saying maybe just
a pants you know like yo yo those are
some dope jeans what kind are they oh
they're YSL jeans you know like no no I
don't I don't know I feel like clothes
is like the bottom of my list of like
interest and things I you ever have the
Balenciaga sock shoes or the giant
chunky Gunners the air Gunners I would
call them around the time when like the
blaga chunkies were out I was like kind
of like 12 no I was like more interested
in like AMC at the time cuz that's what
AMC stock was going stupid so I invested
all my life savings into
it you invested uh in the AMC huh yes I
really didn't care about in balenciagas
So I just went were you on uh are you on
Robin
Hood H you know I'm 17
correct that's true so you couldn't so
what are you asking what are you trying
to do here so how were you buying stock
what do you
mean h how are you how does how does a
14-year-old buy stock I'm talking about
on a simulator bro H so you into the
stock Investopedia have you heard of
that no oh are you uh are you do you pay
attention to the stock market no no
duh dab one time dab dog what are you
trying dab why you trying to get dab
right now dab what year is it bro dab
you dab
first get the Cam Newton bro you got to
do the Cam Newton dab
yeah come on man
yeah yeah yeah to what
bro what you buying stocks stocks and
bonds I like stocks did you buy any
GameStop stock I was more AMC not
gme you watch the new movie though about
the GameStop thing no with Seth Rogan
it's a pretty good movie I was more like
I like with W Street solid movie did you
get into crypto at all
um
nfts you're digging aren't you maybe you
a cryptog I can't let you too much like
you are you a crypto guy I'm a big
Finance guy let's end it you're a big
Finance guy yeah tight so you're a
you're a xrp guy you got
Ripple you got some some
eth any uh any nfts that plummeted in
value something about you gives like you
had a a like six figure nft and you
thought that was the [__] oh no no no
never I I I made my money in crypto
luckily and got the [__] out because I
was like this [__] is too good like six
figures no no no but good money good
money yeah like tuition yeah for like a
year so when are we getting I remember
you told me when I first walked in the
bootle Kev foundation and you're going
to start paying like for kids to go to
college like paying scholarships for
like kids that like are the less
fortunate they didn't say that and you
told me you wanted me to like kind of
Buy in in a way and kind of help and
assist but I told you that like how am I
supposed to I'm 17 bro I lit have no
Finance to back that do you
understand well I didn't say that and
you have a toy company I'm leaking all
your [__] a toy company yeah [__] are
you talking about no like all that [__]
you're trying to make out with your own
like athletic toys I'm like you tell me
you have Devon
Booker do the outro Bro [__] do the
outro it's time to W I'm hungry as [__]
and I have to pee he's going to go eat
pulled pork and vegan ice cream his new
song's going crazy new album's on the
way congratulations sir I look forward
to having back on the show again with
with [__] french fries and chicken
tenders french fries and chicken tenders
and slushies which place would we get
them from you want canes or or
Chick-fil-A um those are your options if
I go to Canes yeah that' be cool but
Chick-fil-A I don't like their tenders
so we got to go kanes then yeah canes
let's get Hella of [__] so we waste food
that's one thing I learned to answer
your question I'm sorry in the music
industry everybody waste food and [__]
oh yeah for sure but it's like fun
though cuz like hell yeah I just wasted
like I bought $5 worth of food and I
Wast wasted like $350 worth there it is
appreciate you pulling up man that was
fun and
interesting boom yo we're wrapping up an
interview man of course want to shout
out to our family at harden baby Harden
Las Vegas celebrating their seventh
birthday this month so happy birthday to
harden uh I want to give a shout out to
the whole family over there when you're
in Las Vegas you got to pull up to
harden tell them that the bootle head
podcast sends you they're going to take
care of you it is the craziest selection
of Premium cannabis in the country all
on Under One Roof you walk in and it's
just a Vibe beautiful Bud tenders
amazing smoke just the illst merch you
know what I'm saying and it's right in
Las Vegas right in Sin City so you land
in Vegas you about to go gamble with
your boys you get in that cab you say
take me to harden they're going to know
exactly where to take you all right
shout out to Hardin go follow him Hardin
Las Vegas or go to the website Hardin
vegas.com